i co-wrote the movie with my brother
tony and my twin brother John is the
editor on the movie Johnny and Tony have
worked before johnny was the editor on
Michael Clayton and he was also the
editor of duplicity so Johnny and Tony
have worked together in celle films this
is the first film that Tony and I worked
on that as writers that it got made we
started when we first started out we
actually did start as a team and we
realized they didn't give you two
paychecks for working together so so we
sort of took our separate careers and we
collaborate over the phone and we share
ideas so it was a sort of a natural fit
when this came around to sort of jump
into it we trust each other we were on
the same wavelength in terms of in terms
of our ideas we we knew going into it
that a good idea was always going to
prevail and and so yeah it's a film as a
collaborative process in and of itself
but in this case it was particularly
collaborative because Tony really did
want to surround himself with people
that he felt comfortable with but when
you have your computer in front of you
now I am on anything i'm working on i'm
researching 10 3 times an hour 5 times a
now i'm born particularly there's
national security minutiae there's
there's sort of big terrorist sort of
activities that he's doing an
interesting side note Tony and I both
probably had a couple 100 hits on online
where we're looking up stuff how do you
fake a United States passport how do you
slip past Homeland Security and you're
always imagining who is out there in the
ether watching it well come come to pass
last week my wife and I applied to go
through the the fast lane through the
security she got in and I didn't so now
i'm starting to wonder who who's rated R
Rahman when Matt Damon and Paul
Greengrass stepped back from it and the
studio wanted to proceed they they
approached a number of people and and
and didn't get I guess the result they
wanted they approached Tony and Tony
came up with a very specific take very
early on and that was that he was going
to you know feather the end of ultimatum
with this film that was this core
concept that was not going to change it
was never discussed that Matt Damon's
character was going to be part of it I
think everybody understood that was
really this was not the time to sort of
like try and
direction and bring him in I don't I
don't think anybody really thought of it
that way but the core concept of having
it overlap with ultimatum was there from
beginning as was as was Aaron cross his
journey those were the two things that I
think Tony had started with that we
built off of we knew that we knew that
that that it was effective to have matts
character in the background we didn't
want it to become a crass sort of like
point oh does not forget that this is
going on and this was like something
that really had to be tracked there were
times during the writing as we were
rewriting that we a couple times the
studio and was wondering do we want more
or less it was that was a topic that was
discussed I think we probably left in
the outline two or three different
places we could have put Matt sort of in
the background that we decided not to
because we didn't want to sort of push
that sort of mixing board element too
far the Olympics are on right now and
you see all the testing that's going on
for anything that's genetically enhanced
anything it could push you farther well
you know the bottom line is there's no
there's no drug testing in war and and
and the reality is is when you really
start to look on this and you go online
within five or ten minutes there's
there's just many many many hits where
you're reading about the research that's
being done to try to enhance the human
body both for war international
intelligence whether it's being able to
go without sleep whether it's a stronger
if you know physical presence whether
it's a mental acuity that you don't have
on it's a big bad world out there and we
spend a ton of money trying to get on
top of it well it's it's an entirely
different character in the sense that
that Jason Bourne is a guy who's been
gone through a rather traumatic sort of
quote-unquote brainwashing experience
training to an assassin obviously his
lost his memory is now trying to find
out one who he is and to you know where
where it came from where it all started
so he's a guy who's searching for an
identity literally Aaron crosses a guy
who's fully cognizant of where he comes
from so so we were never trying to
differentiate it was a natural
differentiation and and if Aaron cross
is now that you've seen the film if
Aaron crosses dilemma could be sort of
summed up I would sum it up and he's a
guy who's managed to taste something
who's managed to experience both
physically and particularly mentally in
existence that he did not have
for and it's now in threat of being
taken away from him and it's the
equivalent of if any one of you or I
were in jeopardy of having our very
identities our personas what we
understand to be existent if that could
be taken away from it at this moment how
far would we go to try to keep that
alive so so I would say the defining
quality or the defining to between them
is that Aaron cross really has free will
and he's tasted something that's almost
a little bit godlike and wants to keep
that intact